is we are collecting evidence here and
collecting facts former Federal
investigator Diane Cutler spent two
decades combating white-collar crime and
Health Care fraud during the pandemic
Cutler turned her attention to U.S
government grants that supported
coronavirus related research in China
how many records have you viewed my
collection is certainly well over 50 000
documents a spreadsheet compiled by
Cutler and reviewed by CBS News
indicates the U.S government may have
paid twice for projects at the Wuhan
Labs through the National Institutes of
Health and the U.S agency for
International Development usaid it's a
categorized it and then drilled down
from there this included possible
medical supplies equipment travel and
salaries so what I found so far is
evidence that points to double billing
potential theft of government funds it
is concerning especially since it
involves dangerous pathogens and and
risky research well intelligence
agencies can agree on how the pandemic
that killed more than 1.1 million
Americans started the FBI and now the
energy Department have found an
accidental lab leak is plausible not
potentially through infected animals at
a nearby Market
at recent Congressional hearings into
the origins of covid-19 the former CDC
director said money from multiple U.S
government agencies supported high-risk
virus research in Wuhan I think it did
not only from NIH but from the state
department usaid and from DOD does
following the money get us closer to
understanding the origins of covet 19.
following the money always seems to work
in investigations Republican senator
Roger Marshall hired Cutler and took her
records to usaid's internal Watchdog
which opened its own probe details of
which have not been previously reported
what needs to happen next next we do
need this 911 style commission I call it
apolitical non-political we need to get
this outside of Washington D.C sources
familiar with the grant records did not
dispute CBS news's reporting in a
statement a spokesperson for the usaid
Inspector General declined to comment on
the existence of a specific open in
investigation why should U.S taxpayers
care I think there's 1.1 million reasons
that American taxpayers should care you
know if a plane crashes we want to find
out why the plane crashes we go to any
length to do that and the hope is we
don't have another plane crash for the
same reason